Welcome to Lesson Seven. This lesson's going to be a little bit
different from the previous lessons in that it's mostly going to
be me and a couple other engineers sharing with you our
real world experiences. So we'll start with how Reddit is architected today.
So, when I started Reddit I knew not much more than
you know right now, and over the years, we've had to scale
Reddit to quite a big size. And I'm going to talk
with Neil Williams, who's the current lead engineer at Reddit. And we're
going to discuss Reddit's architecture, and how it serves billions of
pages per month. It's quite a bit different from the sort
of stuff we've been working so far in this class. But
you'll see how we got there. And then I'm going to spend some
time talking with Chris Chew, who's one of the Udacity engineers.
And Udacity actually uses App Engine to serve their entire website.
Just like you, I was new to Udacity a few months
ago, and I've basically learned as I've gone through this course. And
I've actually really learned to love it, and so has Chris at Udacity. So,
we're going to discuss some of the real-world
problems they've had to face that we
haven't yet had to encounter. Now, nothing in this lesson is required for your
final exam. So, it's just sit back and learn, and we'll have a good time.